John you and I saw the Ukrainian rib Nia
go out to new record weakness I mean
essentially it's a bankrupt Ukraine
isn't it yeah it really is tom and we
need to talk about that because we've
been knee-deep in foreign policy and
troop troop movements meanwhile the
ukrainian currency has been hammered and
the economy in ukraine is getting
absolutely crushed and this year sets us
up for quite a difficult discussion
between Ukraine and their creditors and
one of their big creditors is Russia
there's a three billion dollar bailout
bond and in that bond there's a clause
if Ukrainian debt crosses sixty percent
debt to GDP Russia can recall that debt
early does Ukraine have the ability to
pay that we've talked a lot about
clashes between troops it's really
heating up when it comes to the
economics Joan with other sources that
you have is a ceasefire over it seems
that way i look at the bloomberg
terminal as often you do i look at the
headlines coming through a lot of people
talk about the ceasefire still holding
but on this particular hub this
transport hub that's where it's being
broken but for most of the front line it
looks like it's holding what it will
says I spoke to the Ukrainian finance
minister last week she said it's still
happening the illegal occupation of
Crimea as she called it that is still a
difficulty for them and she said the war
at the moment is making it very very
difficult for her to collect data and
really get a read on how bad this
economy is so yes things are dying down
a little bit but by any stretch of the
imagination you cannot say the economics
of this is over John I also want to ask
you hear about Greece it looks like
Alexis tsipras the prime minister of
Greece did actually blink in this sort
of showdown with the Germans what's next
I look I'm going to take big big issue
with anyone that says Greece has blinked
because a they haven't actually voiced
it official writing to go forward and
ask for this extension and two I would
really contest the point that this is
all about words Greece still wants the
rest of Europe to ease up on those
demands to run a primary budget surplus
of four point five percent greece still
wanted europe to end demands for
austerity greece want europe to admit
that austerity has failed and this
program has not been a success that it's
caused a humanitarian crisis those three
issues and nowhere
near being resolved and if you listen to
Alexis tsipras that is not a man that is
blinking right now John Farrell thank
you so much in the London